nos dicen cada rectángulo es un entero
entonces este rectángulo completo es un
entero y por lo tanto estos dos son dos
enteros cuales de las siguientes
expresiones describen la parte sombreada
del dibujo y ellos sombrear on todo
elige dos respuestas así que pausa el
vídeo e intenta pensar en la respuesta
antes de que trabajemos juntos bueno
incluso antes de ver las opciones hay
varias formas en las que podemos
representar esta parte sombreada nos
acaban de decir que cada uno de estos
rectángulos es un entero y tenemos dos
de ellos podemos decir que estos son dos
enteros esta es una forma de
representarlos
otra forma de representarlos es observar
cada entero está dividido en dos
secciones iguales así que esta es una
mitad esta es otra mitad
esta es una mitad y esta es otra mitad
así que la parte sombreada en total son
una dos tres cuatro mitades podemos
representarla como cuatro mitades o en
lugar de escribir una mitad de esta
forma puedes escribirla como un medio
aquí tenemos otro un medio acá otro un
medio y por acá otro un medio cuántos
uno medios tenemos bueno tenemos uno dos
tres cuatro entonces de qué otra forma
puede representar cuatro mitades bueno
puedo representar las como cuatro sobre
entonces cuál es las siguientes
expresiones describen la parte sombreada
del dibujo bueno en definitiva no es un
entero ya que tenemos dos enteros así
que podemos cancelar esta opción
cuatro medios sí justo es de lo que
hablábamos 4 sobre 24 mitades si también
hablamos de esto y hemos terminado